we do want to get anish's perspective on
this game Anish when your opponent
finishes with 1 hour and 35 minutes on
their clock well you must have survived
a big scare in this one yeah what can I
say great great by Fabiano uh everything
um went according to his plan
but yeah I was very lucky I told him
after the game now okay I'm very sorry
like normally I was I was but today
somehow he was unlucky just an
incredible defense yeah how like and why
like just it's a very unlucky day for
fabians today yeah I just found all the
moves and I didn't know any of this and
um normally I find such sequences only
if I've seen them before was this bishop
to A3 yeah the new idea at least or
maybe it's written down in a file but
the thing is what I played is a Backup
backup option I had some other things
but he move ordered me a little bit like
I think D4 I recollect this bishop B3
idea I think D4 order I don't recollect
now I realize more principles to go to
K8
in C6 but I started to
um to doubt that and then I realized I
mean I knew the technology H6 and
transposed to my backup line which I can
play and then I knew something like ub3
Bishop E6 I believe and I think there's
a game of Shanklin against Aaron Lamy
yeah you know another American against
Dutch clash and and one of your coaches
as well yes of course yeah so I knew
that this is okay I'm closely following
ervin's games and uh you know I can
always fall back on everyone's games if
you're out of book but Bishop A3 I
didn't know and then I realized that
okay Bishop six I'm gonna get a worse
version
and
um yeah I realized it's like I have to
solve the problems and sort of by
elimination I came to the conclusion I
kind of underestimated because I was
counting on CD of course I understood it
could be three my original intention was
to go Bishop E6 but then I realized that
actually it's very unpleasant because it
simply takes goes CD4 and I was thinking
I'm gonna double on the e-file then I
realized I could just play G3
something like win this queen E3 or
sequencito and this position is really
really bad for me so then I realized
that okay the move must be D5 also
because its position looks pretty fine
for black and I originally planned to
take on DC and then I realized that if I
take here first
um I can play Bishop F5 and the
difference is that after he takes place
rookie one I bring the queen right to
the seven on 28 and then
I realized this is probably a better
order and here I thought maybe I can use
it with Knight takes E8
but then I saw this I mean I understood
that he won circuit one because Queen
City Bishop of five Queen Seven and I
realized rookie one Queen E1 and
okay you know although you have these
options yeah yeah confidence is it just
like intuition what do you base your uh
yeah I think it's all the mocking over
the years uh I've become very good at
spotting Perpetual checks and all sorts
of different drawing patterns uh from
all the memes so uh you know the mocking
is rubbing off and eventually um it
helps it helps actually and I think this
was the last critical moment right and
you were sitting on your hands and you
were trying to kind of visualize
everything and finally you weren't
looking at the board and finally you got
up and played Queen yeah that was just
one yes one
uh thought here
um I mean it's sort of clear that this
is a drawing line because I was looking
for a way for him to play on but it was
so artificial like Bishop I mean it is
so incredibly artificial and I have so
many different ways I thought Bishop G4
is good sorry king of one is very bad I
was I was thinking of one was the
critical yeah yeah and then I think
Bishop G4 was very good but also I have
such a margin at this point I mean
material is okay and the pawn 92 is
alive yeah so it was clear that he has
to do this D6 and then this pattern is
pretty simple so I'm speaking of that
moment I think we have it ready to uh
show on the live feed and maybe you can
walk us through what you were thinking
at this point
oh I was thinking something I was just
maybe I just fell asleep
okay
you thought for a while I think you were
in that position no no nobody's filming
you while you're sleeping and uh looking
at you afterwards
or slo-mo
we have slo-mo yeah wow that's what you
want to show off hey you guys you want
to show off the technology of course
okay okay no it's very awkward you know
nobody's filming should film people when
they're eating or sleeping
um
as we all know so yeah very awkward
footage there but in the end I woke up
and
you made the right decision found I
found my perpetually I'm very happy with
that Irish big result big defense for
you tomorrow with the white pieces you
have to put on the pressure on your
opponent how are you going to approach
that game I play Yan yeah I always very
well prepared
but young and ding as we see so far they
of course had a tough Hotel tournament
and um yeah we'll see I mean
I think it's gonna be an exciting game I
enjoy playing you know the great players
and um
yeah very very interesting what will
happen because he's probably the best
prepared player in the world right now
he's done extensive preparation and we
saw in the match also his preparation
was um
probably better than
that of ding curly preparation wise he
was getting better positions with both
colors
and then then ding so yeah it's uh it's
always a challenge and I you know I
really like players that are well
prepared as well because I see it's a
challenge to
try you know and find something
interesting
uh and the tournament in general is very
very exciting now I think I think
Fabiano is doing well I think there is
struggling today but he's of course he's
notorious for um
he's slippery yeah he's notorious for
getting more than what he deserves
[Music]
but we'll see we'll see let's just take
a quick look at this position just sure
yeah okay well so now he's I'm not sure
he's getting the comfortable you know I
saw his position here we were talking
with Fabiano here and I was saying that
maybe you know here maybe it's not as
bad as it looks because why it's king of
course position like positionally it
looks like lost so I guess if it's an
end game like it's maybe lost night good
night but Bishop everything but I think
I think the white king is uh could
potentially be weak because it cannot
find safety on the king side and I
thought the H5 H4 was very strong I
underestimated this movie okay five but
you see here the computer is not hateful
Black's position and I think uh in
indeed because after H5 I think if you
move around it's gonna jump a little bit
so yes let's say H5
three like it goes towards okay maybe
yeah but I uh I see
um potential for black to to get country
play certainly because I think the
whites King is a little uncomfortable
still what I don't like about Rook C7 of
course the evaluation is the primary
thought but the reason you can justify
the evaluation is
I guess
I guess you want to keep material on the
board because I imagine
um if the white king finds itself
somewhere on D2
after let's say eventually yeah just
just for argument's sake
um in an eventual scenario where you
trade the
the Rooks in some way yeah just to
maybe in a position like that even here
you know C5 is good but maybe in a
position like this you want to have one
more look there on the queen side to
bother the king yeah but uh yeah all
very concrete I understand that there is
a idea behind Rook C7 because with that
he trades off whites only active piece
and The Rook was exerting pressure on
the F7 in line 9395 it was it was a
thing so maybe he thinks okay we'll get
rid of The Rook and then we will get
some action but there are very little
pieces uh let's see H5 is probably an
idea of three again Knight F3 now 95 is
coming and another thing he could have
in mind and that's very common theme and
such thing in such cases to trade uh
like that and very often because the
king is disturbing The Rook from
entering the game very often in a
position like this white loses one of
the Pawns because they're getting
attacked you would love to be able to
cast along uh yeah or break The Rook
across yes but here it seems that you're
good because after Bishop C2 there is a
tactical resource it should be three or
B1 yeah and if Rook A8 yeah somehow
maybe this is what he missed because
King E2 doesn't actually work kinky two
you get checked on C4 oh imagine missing
Castle move 24. that that's good that
could be the case uh because yeah this
stuff it's not working I mean it's not
working you it is close but it's just
not quite quite working
yeah we'll we'll see he's very slippery
as I mentioned oh G4 is an interesting
positional idea I like this G4 move this
is what Fabi was mentioned as well
killing the knight uh killing the Knight
yes but
hard to say I still felt you know with
two Rooks let's see now the move I can
get two is easier to make because
there's not one more Rook on the queen
side with more pieces with more Rooks
you're afraid that the truck would be
active and your king in the center will
get in some trouble but uh you know done
that against the others I just yet he's
he's very very
he's one of those players who is always
lucky to the point that you start
wondering maybe it's not just luck and
it's it's a very different brand of
chairs it's not a computer chess like
his games with engineer if you I think
if you check his scent upon uh you know
analysis he plays very bad idea I think
he's uh yeah I think he's playing the
university objective quotes you know in
in quotation marks because
um chess is you know it's not played by
computers and he plays this brand of
Chess similar like Hikaru where it looks
as though he makes a lot of bad moves
because engine don't approve them but
humans tend to
see the point behind his ideas he plays
as human chess and uh
he's selling a lot of
a lot of stuff to his opponents and the
pawns are buying it yeah you know so I
think he might sell something to do that
here but we'll see he's never had such a
bad position so far in the tournament so
we'll see uh we'll see what happens Ali
Raza definitely a good uh Merchant so
thank you very much for giving us your
insights and giving the guys in St Louis
A Commentary break so we'll let you go
we'll let you get ready for tomorrow's
match and we'll see you tomorrow thank
you guys back to you thank you Christian
thank you Anish a commentator break
indeed
takes our job thank you very much for
that